[Music]
all right he's always been around horses
I've had him ever zante with a
two-year-old now 15
Lester Courtney has always loved to load
up and head to the great outdoors he and
his wife Carol have spent a lot of time
with their horses not the recreation but
for work
the Courtney's are loggers part of a
small group
all that remains of what used to be the
foundation of the forestry industry once
the trees are down and trimmed dan and
Maddie come in Lester Courtney is always
logged with horses mules or oxen Lester
believes the machines don't do it better
well we don't tear up the ground like
black cats and jitters we go in and
within six months you won't even know we
were there
cuz it's all grown back again and you
don't have them a big white road makes
it the forest look better the average
horse weighs less than 2,000 pounds
while a piece of heavy equipment can
weigh up to ten thousand because logging
with animals is considered
environmentally friendly it stayed alive
despite technology yeah it's just a lot
of fun and I grew up around it doing it
all my life
Lester has never been able to trade in
his horses for something powered by
diesel fuel when you got something you
like you just keep doing it it's quiet
you don't don't have Lola noise you're
out in there you don't have to smell
that diesel smoke that's the best part
health problems advancing age and poor
lumber prices forced lester courtney to
a reluctant retirement in 2001 pushing
more than a century of family tradition
to a close but he hopes the craft itself
will stay alive not in the history books
but alive out here in the woods the way
it used to be